what is happening reject nation
it's Greg Alec it does John over here
John Humphrey so we're gonna watch the
trailer for Universal Studios this
snowman nomen know nothing about this
movie all I know is that Tuesday was the
day that we couldn't film anything had
attended some things we're catching up
before Comic Con trailers all roll
around and this was highly requested
today oh yeah I've heard very I've heard
a little bit we ran an article on this
so I know that Michael Fassbender Zinn
it I know Val Kilmer's in it oh boy and
that and Rebecca Ferguson arrears Fergus
Fergie Rebecca Ferguson is not very hard
of a name Fergie Fergie's back Rebecca
furry Rebecca furry furry snow / I
didn't thought of the thriving
subculture of people who enjoy dressing
as animals for sexual pleasure and that
is Rebecca Fergus that damn dog shut the
[ __ ] up yet damn dog corner MacGregor
no no interesting in the cartoon
a woman's August walk side
we just found the body interesting
prints
[Music]
is missing whoa yeah she calls himself a
snowman killer mr. police basically
didn't say I'm thinking that he's going
after women that he was across I
understand the only thing we know for
sure is that he's playing games with us
[Music]
finish the way to lure him out
our is we don't know what we're dealing
with
Urmi mm he's been watching it the whole
time fizzing some and cutting things up
into little pieces he's holding if we
don't find him this is never going to
stop
another making moment something you're
not seeing what matters most is that we
celebrate the way this is walk us
together
but he's trying to hide something you
can't force the teachers to fish you
could have saved them get me all the
clues
[Music]
[Music]
that [ __ ] dog done shut up [ __ ] off
John my neighbors don't care they don't
care about noise disruption no no not at
all they're fantastic people there's no
home no they are I know they are there's
them trying to shut their dog up
whatever the dog's name things like
Cassie Chris Cassie stop subscribes it
really did yeah you know I think this
trailer was really good I think it looks
like a really good psychological horror
thriller to be having it I like the
elements of both psychological suspense
and horror all played in one cop hunting
down serial killer thriller it feels
exciting I love Michael Fassbender he's
a fantastic actor he looks like that
kind of detective who the more gets
involved in the East harder it's going
to take on his life I was on above
insomnia but mother's Lodi Acker zodiac
until the two movies out of thinking
about the most during this trailer yeah
I'm glad that we're getting one of these
especially during Halloween time doesn't
look like you're straight up like oh
it's a horror movie but it definitely
has some horror stuff in it yeah so to
have this movie you know during
Halloween time but with a more caliber
cast and you know it seems like they
summed a lot into this yeah I think this
is this looks pretty cool I just hope
that the mystery is satisfying again I
hope so too
I mean it looks like there's a lot to
uncover a lot of questions to be asked
the killer's always one step ahead I've
heard a couple people bring up like a
giallo an Italian horror think about
this like the way they're kind of
portraying the killer in this and some
of the kills well I'm looking forward to
a grisly good time and less you know
snow horror not enough of that not
enough of that snow [ __ ] that's harder
to smile I'm sure the wildlings have
their version of that yeah they're just
the wildlings they don't need to they
should have a community well you can
catch our full trailer review on a
separate video you can subscribe to the
real rejects click that notification
bell that John Humphrey on
in Instagram which watch the other video
if you like if you like commentary and
more than just watching us watch a trade